bonjour benoît bonjour isabelle ça va
oui ça va bien et toi - ça va
yeah yeah d'accord hier
hier je suis allé manger avec la famille
sache pas parmi ce à quoi ce signe à
temps
moustache un gros ventre fin mig
non j'ai pas compris ça je peux par
contre il n'ya pas tromperie famille la
famille d'accord a mis hier tu as mangé
avec la famille d'accord d'accord
maman maman
non non je vois pas ma maman maman
d'accord ok maman ça c'est le style
maman bah quand papa noms d'oiseaux
si je vois vraiment pas papa d'accord le
papa d'accord maman papa
d'accord d'accord alors ça je vois pas
ma maman oui mais un vieux jeu à grand
mère cran mais voilà on emmerde accord
grand mère j'ai pas compris par la mer
papa grand-père d'accord grand père
grand père oui j'ai compris le
grand-père corps voilà où tu as compris
toute la famille
c'est bien il y avait des esquives et
des enfants des enfants
ouais des enfants oui à deux de deux
enfants les milliards de finir fille vit
la première projet d'accord c'est une
vieille fille d'accord la premier steam
finale et deuxième fille ou garçon
la première c'est une fille
le deuxième set un garçon d'accord c'est
un garçon d'accord dont tu es une fille
et un garçon corps
il est l'heure je dois partir tu partes
tu partes
d'accord c'est vrai j'aurais revoir
bonjour repas famille papa
maman
grand-mère grand-père enfants garçons et
filles au revoir